since I haven't been back here for four
years since I've been zero-waste I'm
having a lot of anxiety that's coming up
that I didn't really realize what's
gonna happen this hurts my body and soul
because I know that I can get this
package free somewhere else but for the
challenge I know I gotta make this work
hey guys I'm Stevie and I'm a
sustainability activist with a focus on
the zero waste mindset and today I'm
gonna go to Trader Joe's because I'm
gonna see if I can make a meal without
creating any plastic or trash so what
I'm gonna be trying to make today is a
scalloped potato dish that's just gonna
be a nice little casserole with
scalloped potatoes and then it's gonna
be really creamy I'm I'm excited in a
little nervous okay so the first thing
and foremost I'm looking for potatoes we
have a lot more options than IVA okay so
I got some gold potatoes some russet
potatoes I'm gonna go ahead and opt for
the russet that's very good we can throw
that in too I thought there was only
gonna be apples and onions but we got a
nice hearty selection I'm just gonna
grab some garlic some onions
I've already knocked off the main
ingredients on my list so that's good
this hurts my body and soul because I
know that I can get this package free
somewhere else but for the challenge I
know I'm I gotta make this work so I
might just get it I don't know what
every time I look at them like it's on
its earth for a thousand years I'm gonna
put it down and then we'll come back to
it I got a thing about it
so Trader Joe's has been under a lot of
scrutiny because a lot of customers have
complained that they have a massive
amount of plastic they made a couple
changes the changes the Trader Joe's
have already implemented are no more so
you use plastic bags they've completely
opted out of styrofoam and have more
recyclable options and then they want to
offer more compostable or biodegradable
options a lot of waste haulers won't
accept the compostable and biodegradable
materials because these materials don't
actually break down in their industrial
compost since I know I can get cashews
plastic free I can't physically get
myself to get the cashews in the plastic
so I'm just gonna
optimize and get the organic coconut
milk I'm gonna try and make the flavors
work I'm gonna get garbanzo beans just
in case and I can use aqua file but
maybe for the creamy mix I couldn't find
the nutritional yeast without plastic
that they have one down here that I'm
probably just gonna go ahead and get it
that could be in my little ten percent I
have a 1090 rule so ten percent I can
waste and ninety percent I can try my
best to be zero waste and this just
gives me some leverage so I don't beat
myself up but I feel like if everybody
adopted that rule I think our world
would be a lot cleaner the last thing I
need is herbs and we'll see if that's
without plastic I probably don't think
it will be so we'll see if I can make
that work no could do it I don't need
herbs I can make do without salt to be
nice since I haven't been back here
super four years since I've been zero
waste I'm having a lot of anxiety that's
coming up but I didn't really realize
what's gonna happen I think there's just
so much classic and this goes to nowhere
like this goes past our children's
children's children so the fact that
it's like almond butter that you eat for
like two weeks but it lasts forever it
just doesn't worth it at it I'm having a
moment I started the zero waste mindset
because I started getting obsessed with
mushrooms and mushrooms are really cool
because they pretty much on the
neurological network of the forest and
they recycle and do all these really
cool things and I think that humans can
also be a symbiotic part of the world
and then I wanted to see how I can
reduce plastic in my own life what I
have so far for the potatoes scallops
are the onions the garlic potatoes I got
the asparagus and the coconut milk I
couldn't bring myself to buy the cashews
in the plastic just because I know
elsewhere there's a lot of access for me
to get it involved and then I got the
nutritional yeast because there really
was no other option and the creamy
flavor really does depend on it first to
start the potato scallops I'm gonna go
ahead and just cut the potatoes and then
cut the vegetables and then I think I'm
gonna work on the sauce after and
usually with this recipe it's kind of
like a vegan alfredo and I would use
pasta but I think potatoes are gonna
work this time I think it'd be hard to
find pasta plastic free at Trader Joe's
and now I'm just gonna store all the
potatoes in here
really easy zero-waste snack I don't
know if you've made this potato chips
where you just slice it like this and
then pop them in the oven with salt it's
a game changer and so I'm just gonna put
also asparagus on the top and I think
that's gonna be pretty yummy and these
are just gonna be intermittent layers
for the casserole this is gonna be the
easiest dish ever getting some carbs
you're getting some vegetables and now
I'm gonna set this aside we're gonna
layer this later I'm gonna do the onion
I can't even deal with onion I'm gonna
cry uncontrollably so I'm gonna save all
the food scraps for my vermicompost to
be honest is one of my favorite things
just to feed my little worms and I
actually have a bin in the house it's in
a wood bin and I give them all of my
food scraps and it's actually cool to
think that you're supplying food and you
have like a little ecosystem in your
house I really like that idea this is
just an easy way to divert food scraps
from the landfill food scraps in
landfill is suffocated therefore
creating methane which is a greenhouse
gas I'm gonna throw that in right now
give it directly to the worms I'm just
gonna caramelize the onions first and
foremost with the garlic and then we're
gonna make the cream sauce based around
the caramelized onions and now I'm just
gonna cut the garlic I'm moving these
onions cuz I'm gonna have it I'm having
an episode oh my god it just gets so
choked up when I'm making potato
scallops you know ya ready okay so after
this it's pretty much ready I'm just
gonna start the sauce I usually use
cashews to make a really nice cream
sauce I didn't have that because the
cashews were packaged in plastic and I
couldn't do it instead I bought coconut
milk
and garbanzo beans to see if I can
create that creaminess that I want so
I'm just gonna pour her a little bit of
coconut milk in my food processor I got
this food processor secondhand and you
can find so many things secondhand on
eBay I am gonna be doing the garbanzo
beans in there but I'm gonna go ahead
and pour the aquafaba in here which is
just the garbanzo bean juice this is
just a really good egg replacer for any
sort of recipe I pour half in and then
I'm just gonna see how it goes and we'll
blend it I've never done this before so
gonna be really interesting alright
actually that really did thicken it up
I'm pretty impressed with that
now we have a source of protein look at
that so this is literally the only big
thing that I got in plastic and it
really hurts pretty hard because there's
a lot of ways that I can get it plastic
free but I'm gonna use it and I'm gonna
love it and treat it so well for the
life that it's has and then I'll reuse
it for like a poop bag or something I'm
gonna be pouring the nutritional yeast
in the coconut milk and garbanzo bean
ixed and now I'm gonna do the salt I
could have bought it there but I have
plenty so I assume that every household
has salt as well a little bit of white
cooking wine I'm gonna mix it all up and
then taste it mmm not half that I think
this is really close to the cashew mix
as well I'm not gonna be able to tell
until I actually taste it hot right now
I just tastes like watery garbanzo mush
I'm gonna caramelize the onions I'm
gonna throw the onions in the pot with
olive oil and I'm gonna use a little
maple syrup that I already had any
sweetener will do and then so it looks
really nice okay now I'm just gonna
throw the garlic in last let that simmer
a little bit and then I'm gonna go ahead
and throw in the cream sauce to make
everything stand out with the flavor I'm
so impressed by so this looks really
good I'm gonna try this mmm I've
honestly never done the garbanzo coconut
milk mixed together so I was a little
bit nervous it's so bomb so now that
we've got the cream sauce base and we
have the vegetables chopped it's a
perfect scenario to pour all this
together
I'm gonna do the first layer put these
layers on I'm gonna sprinkle the
asparagus after the potatoes and now I'm
just gonna keep pouring back and forth
I'm gonna pour the cream sauce and then
I'm gonna add another layer and then put
the cream sauce and then add another
layer and then back and forth I'm gonna
get a little fancy look at that I'm
gonna pop it in the oven it's not 400 so
I'm just gonna do that for probably
about 45 minutes to an hour and all of
it should culminate and this is totally
uncovered does not need to be covered
and the sauce actually should be even
thicker after the hour
boom boom I did it this looks great
okay I'm gonna put on the bottom rack
it's at 400 Wow
so I just took it out and now I'm ready
to cut into it I'm a little worried that
it's too watery but we're gonna figure
it out okay so actually it doesn't look
too bad I hope the potatoes already now
I'm gonna dig into this mmm it's just so
good it's actually a different
consistency then it would be with a
cashew cream but I like it a lot
it's super flavorful really creamy and
it has a good body to it I am into it
super buttery it's way more buttery than
the cashew cream I think that had to do
with that garbanzo beans I love this
dish as far as trash goes I'm actually
really impressed with myself I just did
the nutritional yeast I have this
asparagus tag and then I have two rubber
bands that I got from the asparagus that
I'll go ahead and reuse this is my
rubber band bin and then I also with all
the food scraps I put it in my
vermicompost so none of that's going
into the landfill so overall I think
that Trader Joe's has a ton of work to
do to minimize their plastic use but I
am really impressed with how affordable
and convenient it all was and I really
hope sometime soon have way more options
that are sustainable yet affordable and
convenient for everybody
[Music]